I mean let us soak you in for a minute
brought my pom-poms do you see the
pom-poms on her fingernails look at this
I I just have to say like we were
planning to talk about your hair and I
just it's like I can't not talk about
your hair it's so I don't know why my
hair has become a thing this is I've
always had big hair I just this is my
hair
so comfortable thank you is it like the
bigger the hair the closer to God yes
I just like big things
yeah the hair gotten bigger though
through the years I I don't know I think
it's just different is my hair's just
blonde I mean look at my hair there it's
pretty big oh my gosh
it was oh my God you and I Theresa kind
of had the same hair like yeah you watch
poison ivy this like B movie I did back
when I was 16. yes I did hair yes
exactly yeah I know it is that's where
the inspiration came from it's so long
and luxurious as well well you got to do
something you know when you get older
when you get mature by the way you look
fantastic thank you what is the story
behind the dream job with the pom-poms
oh well I've always wanted to be a
Dallas cowgirl cheerleader yeah
well you didn't become a Dallas Cowboy a
cheerleader but you did become probably
the most famous psychic medium on them
right yes
yes I've seen every episode of Long
Island Medium I love how much closure
you bring to people and what you do and
I also love how accessible you are you
go out on the street and whether you're
in a grocery store or a deli if you get
a message you just give it to people
right I say that's why I'm good at what
I do because I sense and feel things and
I learned the years of growing up with
all my anxiety and everything it was
because I was holding everything in I
wasn't expressing it so it's just easier
for me to tell someone something and and
I feel that if Spirit shows me enough
things to get me to say something then
I'll say it I mean I just don't I'm
always sensing and feeling things but
there's like Spirit has to show me three
things before I actually will approach
someone it's so fascinating to think
what could have been if you didn't like
listen to this gift you know I I don't
know I honestly I don't know and I
always say that I have I had I still
have the greatest support uh you know my
parents foremost and foremost I mean
they have supported me with everything
that I do even though my dad is still
like really freaked out about what I do
yeah oh yeah you know like I'll come
over and he'll be like just make sure
you take the dead people with you you
know he's always like you know
how's that though when you were a kid
and you were like starting to to do that
like how did your parents accept that
you were just crazy no I no one no one
thought I was crazy that was the thing
you know I come from a very spiritual
family and a very strong faith family
and you know my mom would always be like
oh that's nice that's lovely and no one
really even made a big deal about the
things I would say or do and it wasn't
until it was later in my 20s early 30s
that I discovered that Not only was I
able to connect with my own departed
loved ones but everyone else's wow you
um I Heard
um did a reading at a gynecologist's
office oh there is no boundaries wow I
No Boundaries
you doing in interview in the
gynecologist's office of course yes as
long as the cameras pointed the right
way over the show exactly exactly so
absolutely just go down I don't even
remember I don't remember half of the
things that I say or do because you have
to realize they're not my thoughts
feelings and emotions and you know this
is one of the things that I loved about
um you know for years because I can't
explain what happens to me it just
happens I don't know how it works well
that I know is that Spirit just starts
to clear out my own personal thoughts
feelings and emotions and they start to
replace them with things that mean
absolutely nothing to me but a
life-changing to the person that I'm
speaking to so you just sort of step
aside and something comes through you
and then are you are still present are
you thinking about laundry or things you
have to do now what is going on I can't
even tell you I don't even remember what
happened a half hour ago and I and I
actually did something with Dr Ayman
where he actually read my brain as I
read somebody and and it actually showed
that I'm able to access a part of my
brain that we typically don't and that
my brain like shows no activity as I'm
reading wow yeah that is so wow wow I
just love also that you are both
giving of yourselves right now and
you're both doing podcasts will you both
talk about that really quickly well we
haven't spoke
you had the result I don't even know how
it affected your life yeah it affected
you we did a podcast crossover my
podcast Hello Ross Theresa came on and I
went on hers uh Hey spirit and she gave
me a reading and it was so touching and
because you know we've talked openly
here about losing my parents and and
people very close to me and it it's so
tough and I think anyone who's lost
anybody whether you're religious or
you're not or you believe in afterlife
or not you just kind of want to know
that they're okay right and that's what
you give to people and I have to say
there are even things I saw in this this
reading you told me that I didn't get
and then my mom's best best friend
watched later and she was like Ross that
was what she was talking about that's
what happened
oh please yeah I want to see this me too
I literally started to write mimosas
that's so funny you have right there
yeah it was wine it was she was always
like oh God if you gave her a glass of
Pinot Grigio she'd eventually do
something
can I show you something sure I don't
know if it is if I show you her picture
no no
she's holding a mimosa
shut up I swear right there I see it
it's a mimosa it was so crazy because my
mom didn't drink Mimosa so I corrected
Teresa and then I looked up on the Shelf
in front of me and there was my mom
holding a mimosa like dummy listen to
Teresa I did drink mimosas and it's like
I didn't even know that and it that kind
of validation that's why I'm so
fascinated by what you do is because you
give those of us who are in such great
pain a little something to hold on to I
think also
um I I heard you're on the 10th
anniversary of your tour and you're
actually going to go overseas now that
you're a national Treasurer what is that
tour going to be like oh I I don't know
I'll find out how can I get there I have
seen you go live and she's in a room
full of like 2 000 people Teresa I don't
know how you do it you that's why you
came to my live show too yeah at the
Paramount in Huntington here in Long
Island and you're going to read our
audience coming up here on the show yeah
which you don't want to miss
is going to read the room literally
[Applause]
[Music]